谢谢大家 那个两个钟没有update市场
然后我记得上一次讲的时候
好像是3月中码 3月18号左右
然后那个时候呢
我们是看市场上的这个买牌的力量和筹码
感觉在月底前是会有一波小的反弹的
那我当时好像记得让大家小心的是
4月2号的这个tariff就是那个关税的这个最后的政策
然后要小心整个4月份的时候
公布了3月份的经济数据
但是在那个之前呢
其实当时是有CTA的买牌
有那个基督墨的pension fund rebalance
然后有那个vote control strategy都卖光了
然后整体的市场的这个风险偏好情绪
当时已经到了比较差的极限
那么现在回顾来看呢
就说4月2号之前市场会提前self
然后再加上了上两周的时候
就特别在周末的时候
特朗普对于关税发表了很多很多言论
就特别是他提到关税可能会变更多
在这之前就是这一轮下跌上周的时候
其实他讲到了recipical tariff
讲到了对于比方说
进口维尼拉石油的国家要征收额外25%的关税
所以现在对于中国来讲
中国的关税已经变成了39%加上25%了
就那个当然他也提到就是
如果抖音的项目会被那个
抖音卖掉的话
他的关税会减少
那这个其实减少多少已经不重要了
就整体的他这个
我们会看到大部分的特朗普的关税
都是对中国来的
然后最终的目的可能都是对中国来的
然后我觉得我最近可能要做一次
比较大的调整
就是对于特朗普政策和关税政策
做一次调整
因为其实你记得年初的时候
我们认为特朗普的关税
他有三方面的政策
第一方面关税
第二方面斗争
第三方面那个移民
这三方面政策结合在一起
可能导致tale risk导致尾部的风险
我这一贴了一张比较好笑的图
是我一个好朋友在圈里面发的
然后把结过来
争取他同意之后结了过来
然后这三方面政策产生的tale risk
是可以导致血流成河的
我们在年初的时候
并不觉得这个是一个大概率事件
或者说我们说美国今年要关注什么东西
就上次我会也讲
就是今年只需要关注一件事情
就是增长是不是能够持续
美国是不是会增长
这三方面政策会不会导致增长衰退
那么本来我给出的判断
是增长不太会衰退
但是从周末来看
仅仅tale risk的这个影响
可能会比我们预期的情况更差
它对于关税的这种执着的程度
其实是非常危险的
简单说一下市场前一段时间的表现
就说我们会看到他这一周
其实现在短期的开始看到反弹了
就昨天看到一直是反弹
因为我觉得现在市场基本是三不走
就是短期市场是三不走
就是特朗普发推先跌一波或涨一波
不管他是发推正面的就涨一波
发推负面就跌一波
然后政策出来再来一波
然后政策implement实际落地开始反向走
这个趋势从我们看到挺明显
就是包括这几次Mexico
加拿大和墨西哥的关税
包括现在关税其实都是这样
所以我们看到要躲4月2号
它的真的下跌是上周
就是三四个交易日之前
如果说4月2号发生什么情况
我觉得短期来看4月2号
市场现在预期性很差
那么这么差的预期
如果真的落地 削子落地
说不定它会反弹 会涨也不好说
我觉得基本的判断
就非常短期的基本判断
我是觉得会反弹的
就是关税负面的关税全部落地之后
它有可能会反弹
但是如果说这些关税真的是落地了
这一轮反弹要继续延长
你要继续交易下仓位
因为我现在对于可能发生衰退的影响
可能发生衰退的概率
其实我觉得在变高
这是高升的一个语窍
高升大概于9%
Effective Tariff
我看新闻 我觉得可能在15%
就是市场的预期普遍
Consensus在15%到18%
这个Effective Tariff
那么之前大家觉得这个
Critical Good 包括
这个Reciprocal Tariff
这个东西它是吹吹扭 说说的
但是人家大到致解
人家告诉你 我要这么干
它就是铁着头 真的要这么干
这个事情是不是引涉到
比方说斗志上面
是不是引涉到
比方说真的把非法医民全部驱逐上面
为了选票或者为了什么
马卡之士干这些事情
现在不好说
但是确实有这个风险
但仅仅只看现在确实要落地的tariff
我觉得美国经济增长
就会非常难看
那个当然不排除
就我们说短期的话
不排除在4月2号时候
或者4月2号之后两个星期
有一个就是我们叫做 positive surprise
就是它那个实行的时候
没有像这个现在实行的这么坚决
就这个这个是有可能
为什么我们对我对tariff这么反感
我说一下大致的我的逻辑理由
就是过去20年 30年以来
美国经济运行的基础是什么
它是把很多的制造业
低端制造业外包到了所有的国家
这个我前两天
我今天早上写了一个推特也讲了这个事情
那么外包到其他国家之后
美国承担的是花耳机金融
然后另外一部分的承担的是那个创新
就硅谷那些创新
所以它其实给出的是高负价值
和美国企业的盈利
你虽然说这个
比方说我们说以后有个车
FSD的汽车
那可能做牛马生产汽车的中国人
那产银行车可能一半美金就搞定了
然后现在产银行车比外币的
5%的5%的10%
10%都到不了的5%
5%的马损甚至是副马损
他都愿意去看
但是FSD卖多少钱
马损80%
然后芯片90%
芯片因为你制造芯片50%
然后你芯片IC design的公司
可能还拿了60%到70%
所以芯片可能最后是90%的马损
80%到90%的马损
所以美国公司赚走了大部分的钱
然后美国变了很有钱
中国牛马多了很多很多的生产
但是不赚钱
那么赚钱的人就可以消费
所以以前民主党是国家花钱
不管是借债花钱
他最后是转移支付
把这个钱给到了老百姓
所以美国的消费占全世界的30%
那是美国的人口
只占全世界的5%
你说一个人口占5%
消费占30%的国家
有没有可能把牛马的生产
要接回去
那没有可能进的
这肯定接过去
就算不在中国
他也会在印度
会在非洲
会在其他国家在越南
但是不会到美国
因为你有30%的消费
有5%的人口
就说穿了我很有钱
我为什么去卷牛马的事情
不会去卷了
这个
这个是我觉得从特朗普政策上的
一个很大的悖论
但是谁在这个全球化中间真正获利
却在这个全球化中间
真正获利的是美国人
美国的企业
其实也是美国的老百姓
包括那些马卡的人
因为他们是获得了
比方说social welfare
然后house care
获得了保证金
失业金
然后这些补助
甚至到美国的非法移民
他们都获得了补助
都是发了钱
这些钱是美国企业
美国盈利
美国知识产权
和它全球的影响力
包括美元的影响力
这些东西带来了
那美国带来了消费
所以你说这些生产的国家比方
说今天早上有个新闻说
中国 日本 韩国联合在一起
你要对于美国反对美国加关税
没有用
你是以方
人家是假方
你就以方对假方
永远是没有话语权
所以全球化中间获利最多的是美国
如果你要打破这个过程
让这个需求变少
其实特朗普做的事情
减少斗局
减少需求
然后加关税
不让美国的需求到全世界去
首先影响的
不是美国制造业回到美国
或者美国制造业那些人
首先影响的是在全球化中间
获得盈利的美国公司
所以这个时候就是
资本市场受到学习
那么我们要准确的去想
这个tariff它到底是虚张声势
还是争得搞
现在争得搞的概率我觉得变大
但高尚的预期
拱本这是拱本的一个预浅
5%的tariff
Ritz scenario到15%
我觉得到15%的Ritz scenario
非常有可能
因为Additional Reciprocal Tariff
它这里提到Additional Reciprocal Tariff
那些东西
比方说它对于文尼拉石油要加税
今天昨天跟俄国没有谈妥
说谁买俄国石油
我要加二次关税
就是买俄国石油都给你加税
它对于各种外交政策
它都可能来来回回的加关税
所以这个关税
包括我们看到的Auto和Auto Part
其实这个都已经确定性的落地了
就是确定性要出来了
在4月3号的时候
包括它对于芯片对于金属这些东西
我觉得都是比较确定的要出现
对于15个国家加税
这15个国家跟美国的贸易关系
80%到90%
所以受到影响
我觉得
而且这个预期是要对这些国家加
15%到20%的同意的关税
所以受到影响
可能就是在市场线的consensus
觉得是在15%到18%之间
15到18比它高盛预期的最高线还要高
我引用一下狗们对于今年年底的一个预期
Q4大概是1.5
那么关税出以二来则算
出以十来则算的话
那么我觉得根据它的1.5的预测
那么到Q4的话
就会变成1
那Q4全年1%的话
那么这个recession的概率就是50%
这个时候我个人的一个判断
但是50% 50%认为就是发生recession
就是发生我们年初讲的
伪布风险概率到50%
就是如果这些tile of trend
这些关税全部被implement
被实行的话
这个中间可能会剃除一些因素吧
就比方说auto part
你对于墨西哥加税
墨西哥有40%的车的生产
车的零配件可能在美国生产
这些东西可能会被剃除一些
但是marginally影响可能也就2%
所以最终的话15%还是能够喷得到
就新大市场concerned 15%到18%
所以15%还是能喷得到
那么整个市场下跌其实分成两个lag
就是我们看这一轮如果下跌
会分成两个lag
那我们之前好像也讲过
就第一个lag是对于
通缩或者是对于经济衰退的一个预期
这个预期一旦出现
就像我刚刚讲的这些预期出现
包括它的专关生产政策
可能会对美国全球企业造成影响
所以原来估值更高的全球企业
全球性的企业互联网企业
高科技公司AI相关的东西全部暴跌
那么这一轮下跌其实不是deep seek造成的
是这个特朗普造成的
这个是对于衰退的预期的下跌
那么衰退预期下跌之后的第二步
是衰退实际出现
然后开始下跌
那么如果说我们认为这个衰退
不出现
那它很有可能就是4月份
但是衰退如果出现
那么我们说年底到4Q4到1%
1%的GDP growth的话
那么它有可能出现在42或者43
要等这个tariff实行
然后tariff的implementation出现在经济体上面
然后这个时候才会能够出现
第二个两个的衰退
所以这个时间就会比较长
所以我们当我们说
如果是现在tariff预期非常慢
那么在短期里面
我觉得是会又会有反弹
因为tariff比较满的时候
市场预期15到18
那么其实市场pricing
它马上会加tariff
马上会加滑水
但其实它不会
也就是说不是4月3号
就是4月3号后天
大后天马上加滑水
而是说它即使实行
它也有什么一个月
这种grease period
然后有一个月的时间
或者是更长时间
来做一个调整
exceptable order也会给这种调整
那么在中间还会有
legalization有谈判
有一些back and forth
会有一些撤回 剃除
那么最终落实的tariff
会比市场现在预期的差要低
所以我觉得从短期来讲
就是经济上短期来讲
从关税的预期上
现代市场预期非常非常冰点
那么underdeliver的概率
在4月3号的时候会更加大
所以会有一个surprise
也就是可能会有一个
会有一个正面的这个
虽然预期很差的情况
就会有一个正面的surprise
或者说利空出境的反弹
有靴子落地的反弹
中间最重要的就是divibrility
就是大概以什么时候实行
一个是什么时候实行的关税
第二个是divibrility
关税会实行多久
那这些东西出来以后
就是我觉得会有反弹
但是如果说对于tariff
tariff确实在4月3号
4月2号出现了这样的一个情况
就是关税的情况
那我们可以有理由的认为
就是今年经济是不会好
今年经济不会好
而且很多跨国企业现在的估值
还是过高
我倒会讲一下
我觉得哪一些公司可能是过高
这我放大一会儿再讲
但是这个就会给市场一个机会逃跑
就是说如果说真的是关税
是比较负面
像现在预期这样加上去的话
那么接下去就是反弹
就应该继续讲仓
再讲一些仓文
那么虽然我们看到年初的时候
其实我们可能是半仓
那么半仓中间下跌
要看手上持有的股票
如果是Mac attack
大科技股
我觉得可以熬
但是如果你手上是financial
然后industrial
这些股票
那其实这些股票
才是经济衰退中间
会跌得最惨的
不是高科技股票
高科技股票已经跌过一轮
这一轮
我觉得这一轮的市场
跟2018年有点像
2018年s&p下跌了25个点
对吧
然后下跌了2018年四季多的时候
s&p下跌25个点
然后2018年最开始
跌得最凶了
也是Logitech
大的科技公司
但是你回头看大的科技公司的估值
其实从估值角度来说
已经天液漏了10年最低的
拿一些半导体的公司来说
比方说英伟达
比方说Babao
那这些公司
它不太受到经济周期影响
它的引力更加跟Delacent的投资相关
你如果算大科技公司
Microsoft Google
然后Meta
那个这些家伙们
对于Amazon
对于那个数据股的投入
有可能会放缓
但是他们明年的增长
还是很确定的
就是明年
主要说英伟达20的增长还是有
今年50%以上
然后像那个Mabao
这两年
不管怎么说
它增长70%到80%还是有的
但是他们都
Price在Forewall P20倍左右
所以我是觉得像Magatech
包括Sambic Connector
它这一轮确实下跌得很狠
因为这是一开始
这个两个来的下跌
其实本质上第一个是杀固址
第二是杀引力
先杀固址再杀引力
杀完固址之后
他们引力杀
杀不了太多
但是Financial Service
就是金融公司Industrial
那这些包括这个无物行业
那这些东西
它杀固址会杀得很狠
这个
这个是我觉得一个比较
比较就是我要出
就是如果你要出货
如果手上还有很多头寸
那么这些头寸
哪一些头寸
優先
万一发生关税的时候
優先走
那这个是我个人的看法
就是最后我们还要看
4月2号它的关税
和关税最后实施怎么样
那么如果说真的实施
大概率经济好到哪里去
然后除了经济好到哪里去
通胀也好到哪里去
然后这个也是高升的一个预期
但是高升这个预期
可能是根据10%的tariff来计算
那么增加了5个点的
那个 effective tariff
这个实际的关税
对于整体的这个通胀影响
我觉得neutral的
平的那就不一定会增加太多
而且通胀这个影响吧
在很多时候你加关税的时候
是立马显现的
就立马会发生
比方说你现在在4月份
出确定这政策
6 7月份6月份给它加上去
或者是5月份6月份加上去
那你可能在第二季度
第三季度的时候
就立马就发生了
这个严重的严重的问题
就是通胀的问题
但是你后面的这个通胀
又不会一直持续
因为你该发生的已经发生了
所以顾价上升
就是一次
不是持续性的上升
不是螺旋性的工资的上升
它持续性的上升
而是说你比较说你的中国牛马
生产也不然1万块钱
然后你给它加了65%关税
变1万6
那这个价钱马上pop up了
但是中国牛马会活得更惨
然后他们会生产变成8000块钱
然后不会持续性的
像螺旋性的上升
所以关税的影响
它在通胀上面影响更多的是短期里面
但是在短期里确实不太好
因为它会影响连锁的政策
那我说一下连锁的感受
连锁会对inflation
第一个就是出现inflation的情况
连锁会比以前less hogglish
这个是肯定的
因为增长不好
但是它也没有特别大
就不是inflation一旦出现通胀
它就立马就转换成
它有可能要加稀
或者是它有可能要去搞QT什么的
所以这个是不转换的
而且连锁我觉得在下一次会议中间
对于现在的经济数据
没有办法像上一次这样直接
把它这个清料淡泄的给带过去
就说认为这个数据是短时的
然后我们再观察一下
没有什么好观察
因为下一次比方说6 7月份的时候
那个时候的经济下行的
如果关税真的这样加上来
经济下行的趋势就会很明显
而且经济下行的预期也会很明显
关税加多少
后面经济会衰退多少
这是很明显的数学公式
所以年储可能会在7月份的时候
我觉得可能7月份会做一次降息
就是在我做降息
但是连储降息的次数不会太多
因为它的弹药
就同时的话
你关税这东西恶心在哪里
就第一个
它让你短期里面弹药没有了
因为通胀不低的
就是你会看比方说高盛预期三年五
我们就算关税增加的更高
然后通胀预期没有变化的话
也用在三年五
三年五是没办法降息的
所以你会让连储弹药用完
简单来说你把经济带差了
但是连储弹药用完
这个状态和去年年底是很不一样的
去年年底连储有无限的子弹
它可以随便降息
通胀很好
经济也很好
经济一旦发生不好
连储有很多子弹
所以它是一个非常Bullish
就是非常牛的牛式的一个状态
包括当时在特朗普选上去以前
还有一个Federal Pun
国家还要花钱
所以两方面的动力
可现在是完全相反
现在是国家把连储的手一连绑上
连储也没办法的短期有动作
连储即使要有动作
也要等通胀预期下赶
就是两者到今年年底
它没有办法再涨
因为特朗普的影响已经显现了
那么这个时候才有可能
就比较大的动作去做事情
除非发生比较深度的衰退
比较深度衰退
我又觉得不太会
就现在算下了不太会
除非他搞得更过分
等下说他搞完特朗普再去搞下斗志
然后再去搞下那个移民
那么这三个东西一个个搞完
那就深度衰退了
那有可能没连储可以采取更加激进的政策
所以但是我会看到风险资产
现在处于一个比较perfect disaster
就是正好到了连储也动不了
然后经济会被他搞衰退
这么一个状态里面
就是这个状态是对NASDAQ不好
对于很多比方说
NASDAQ相关的风险资产
包括比特币咱也都是不好的
就是所有的资产都受到这个影响
就是处于一个衰退了
但是通脏没下来
然后连储干不了什么事情
要等到年底通脏最后预期再下来
时候才能有所动作
所以这个是美国现在一个不太好的状态
但是我还是觉得薛子洛地是会反弹
最近一两个星期跌了有点狠
薛子洛地是会反弹
我觉得大概率可能甚至现在大家市场
我觉得对于下就是3月份经济数据
已经完全没有预期了
所以现在经济数据出来好的数据
大家会说下个月要跌了
下个月数据就废了
然后出来坏的数据就会说
你看数据废了吧
现在就处于这么一个状态
那么真的数据出来
不管是好还是坏
那么到底会怎么样
现在反而不好说
就说市场一般是有个提前量的
当我讲到4月份4月2号
经济关税政策之前要避一避
很多人都会去避
它避都是避在之前
但是等它真的出来
反而就是有可能会有波反弹
所以我觉得这个概率还是挺大的
就是关税出来之后
一个 positive surprise
然后给到市场一些好一点的预期
然后给一个 catalyst
让大家再降一下仓位
我觉得这个概率挺大
那么降仓中间的
我觉得选择的标底应该是
非高科技股票
非高科技股票可能会更好一点
那么这个是 cds
就是我们说到什么东西
接下去讲的问题
就是什么东西
我们要表扬说
高科技股票我刚刚讲了
其实估值现在10年已经最低了
很多三比肯道特估值已经很便宜了
那么什么东西呢
是可能我们觉得更好的一个
更加 overpriced 东西
首先 cds 现态是 overpriced
就虽然这一波上涨
我记得我在一个星期前
在群里大概在这个时候
在群里讲到过
就说我们应该
如果你们要做空股票
你们不如去买 cds
因为 cds 还没有调整
它是智候在股票后面做了调整
股票已经跌了
但是 cds 还没有上去
标上去了
但是即使在现代水平
你放回五年十年看
这个 credit default
credit default 水平跟股票不一定相关
股票中间是 compounding return
但 credit default 的这个水平
就是应该同一水平来比较
根据过去五年来说
现在还不是特别高
包括跟去年八月份差不多
但是其实如果衰退的话
那么这个往上走
100到200倍 cds
非常非常正常
因为这个不是衰退水平
你觉得衰退的话
cds 完全应该往上跑
所以这个是一个
我觉得 cds credit spread
是一个如果你要压住衰退
一个不错的一个标顶
就是这个其实还没有被 overpriced
那么还有什么市场
就市场
我们找定价过分的点
还有什么东西
现在处于 overpriced
可以去做空的
你可以去空 cds
就是买cds 就做空
那么还有什么东西被真正 overpriced
我觉得真正被 overpriced
是 the rest of the world
包括欧洲和中国在内
就特别是中国
这个是被 overpriced
所以我今年确实就说
我们没有在年初的时候倾仓
但是我也确实买了横升的put
横升put 最近两个星期给我带来了
就 cover了我很多在美股的算是
基本上都 cover了
但横升put 还是表现不错的
就说那个虽然仓位不是很大
那么但是我是觉得
就是说中国被加了百分之
将近六十就二十五
二十三十九加二十五
就你你加上去
被加了这么大的关税
虽然后面的关税可能会被取消
但是主要的关税都对着中国来
去年没有关税的情况下
我们百分之五十的GDP增长的归因
是归在这个出口上
出口最终的目的都是美国
有百分之三十的全球消费在美国
那中国在今年被加了关税
被针对性的全部围堵性的加了关税
经济是不会好
那么接下去就是你会看到
就你最近很多东深西想讲中国很强
但是问题是你看到
包括上海的消费数据
深圳的消费数据
包括全国的税务数据
一月份 二月份的税务数据
税务下降百分之三点几
那么这一些
这个非税收入加百分之十一
你要看正常税务
非税收入这个
其实远洋补劳
这个不算了
你要把那个正常的税务数据
下降百分之三点九
三点八
这个就是看到了全国的
这个真正的经济状况
就是一二月份
在去年九月份开始
放了那么多钱以后
现在看到的这个经济的状况
还是在一个
就等于已经是掉落下来
从一二月份来看
经济数据已经掉落下来
所以这个还没有被关税真正
implement
所以我会觉得你现在在香港
说的这些中国公司的盈利情况
DBC带动中国这个东深西讲
我觉得每一次东深西讲
就是给大家送钱
这么一个机会
所以我不买张港股的
那我觉得如果说美国得了感冒
那全球心脏病
就是中国的心脏病
如果说美国出来表说
假设这个4月2号和后面的
这个关税调整
没有那么严峻
那么中国有可能会还喘口气
所以中国只有可能在美国关税
不严重
美国经济不衰退
变了很好的情况下
就是中国可以不错
因为我们是一方
只有假方给给单子
然后假方日子过得好
所以以方才过得好
假方现在自己不愿意给单子
然后可能还要衰退
以方怎么可能过得好
这肯定不会好
所以这个我觉得是现在还是被 overpriced
所以你如果是空头的话
你看一下cdx
看一下那个 quality fault
然后看一下中国
看一下港股
那么这个是大致的一个情况
那么美国的科技公司和美国大公司
我觉得就像我刚刚讲的
大致路径很有可能
还是还是18年的这个走势
就说有梦想的公司高估值的
杀一轮估值之后
杀盈利杀不下去了
所以后面其实是包括18年的
18年四季度后面那一波下跌
其实Logitech相对来说是比较 defensive的
跌的凶的都是
后面那轮跌的凶的都是那些实体经济的东西
所以这个也有可能是这一轮
差不多的某时候个人感觉
所以这个判断
然后最后raids的一个判断
就是说raids的判断
我是觉得继续steepen
因为毕竟你的通脏预期放在那里
然后虽然有个衰退的预期
但是通脏预期放在那里
raids或steepen
raids steepen的话
就是你们做空
比方说觉得市场不好
不要随便去买tlt
不要随便去买常债
这个不是一个很好
压住美国衰退的标的
raids不是一个很好标的
更好要求可能cdx
你就压这个quaddy force
或者你去直接去压在港股上面
我觉得可能会更好一点
好吧
我今天大概跟大家这样沟通